welcome back to cbs mornings where it is
not time for talk of the table because
instead of talk of the table we are
taking a look at a revealing new memoir
from renowned chinese contemporary
artist and activist ai weiwei now ai
weiwei is now one of china's most famous
dissidents but he also designed the
iconic stadium for the 2008 olympics in
beijing he's regarded as one of the most
important artists working in the world
today full stop ai weiwei spent an
afternoon recently in new york city with
anthony mason for his first tv interview
about his new book it's called one
thousand years of joys and sorrows i'm
happy to say anthony mason joins us now
in studio anthony good morning good
morning as you're about to see ai
weiwei's work is provocative and to some
even offensive a decade ago the chinese
government secretly detained him it was
during his 81 days of confinement that
ai weiwei realized he needed to write
down his story
you wrote this book really for your son
yes the purpose is to leave something
for him because i'm
kind of feel i can't disappear anytime
ai weiwei has disappeared once already
the world-renowned artist who's
literally given the finger to chinese
authority in his work
was seized at the beijing airport in
2011 and held in secret detention
how long did you think you would be
there the interrogator
kept telling me
don't take it lightly you have to be
prepared this could be a long long
tunnel he later made dioramas showing
his small cell and the two guards who
stood over him night and day
once you're totally cut off from the
reality
you realize
they are ruthless
and they can do anything they want to do
the world protested
and he was released after 81 days
but in his confinement weiwei had gained
a new appreciation of what his own
father had been through
that's my father
ai ching a revered poet had been a
revolutionary he's standing
right here and a friend of mao zeitong
and that is a chairman
until
1957 right when you were born that your
father essentially was sent away yes i
was born the year my father was exiled i
ching was purged from the communist
party and sent with his family to a
remote camp called little siberia where
he was sentenced to cleaning public
toilets it's the worst thing
a man can be punished to do were you
aware of that as a little boy
how humiliating that was to your phone
oh yes i every day i
have experienced that
to see him how he has been
insulted in exile weiwei's father was
not allowed to write and fearful of the
red guard he burned his prized
collection of books
i remember those books are very
difficult to catch fire because the
paper is too thick how did it feel to
burn the books you loved well while your
life is being straightened
basically you have no feeling about
anything
because
you sense your father
is getting very
scared how do you think it affected you
as a boy
to see your father go through that it's
very hard to measure i think
maybe i become very realistic and also i
see how how low humanity can go this is
your old neighborhood
yes i basically spent
many many
years here when china opened to the west
ai weiwei went to new york in 1981.
did you like new york
uh it's more than like it it's
overwhelmed browsing the strand
bookstore he discovered the philosophy
of andy warhol that's the first english
book i ever bought what did you find in
this book that so interested you rojo
represent the pure memory card to get by
he drew portraits on the streets
foreigners he remembers were the most
difficult customers
very second they want to bargain they
will say oh it doesn't look as good you
know
did living in new york change the way
you saw things
oh yes i you know that's most
important time for me is between my 24
to 36 yeah
it gave me a
clear understanding about what i'm going
to do on his return to beijing weiwei's
provocative work destroying one
priceless urn painting the coca-cola
logo on another would mock chinese
conventions and communist authority even
a police beating didn't deter him but in
2015 after the government gave him back
his passport he left the country
ai weiwei lives in portugal now where
he's collecting the roots of dead olive
trees for a future project
but his main studio remains back in
china most of your work is still done in
china
oh
99 percent
in china but every day i call my mom the
last sentence my mom would say do not
come back she says don't come back no
she's almost 90 years old
she terribly miss me yes but
she keep calling me is trying to
convince me not to go back
she's scared
she's
totally scared she doesn't want to see
you go through what your father did but
more so she didn't want my son to
experience i have experienced
that's what she really worried it's
about about the eye law ailao his only
child is now 12. in his memoir weiwei
writes of his son telling him
that he'd put a hammer in a freezer yeah
he froze the hammer in a block of ice
yeah the hammer ailao told his father
represents ai weiwei
and when the ice thaws he said
the hammer is still the hammer you are
the hammer yes you think i'm in the
hammer
so funny
you feel like a hammer i more feel like
a nail
[Applause]
[Laughter]
by the way he's released a book of poems
by his father who has been by the way he
was rehabilitated in china and is again
a prominent poet the illustration on the
cover is done by his son wow i low who
was obviously a philosopher
at the age of 12. yes go back to what
the sun said at 12 years old a block of
ice he puts a hammer in the block of ice
wow and he says when it thaws it's still
a hammer um
it's very powerful interesting to see
the relationship that he has with his
dad yes now that he has with his son
father and son this is a very rich
territory this is really a book about
fathers and sons and also about memory
uh he highway says the state was a
machine that sucked up memory and
bleached it white which i think is why
this book is so important the new york
connection is also fascinating much like
andy warhol his personality and his
artwork are kind of one and the same
exactly i love his mom saying don't come
his mama loves him must be hard that's
hard very hard he says if she gets ill
he'll go back but
but it's rough and very very very
powerful